play but yeah it should be a very very  interesting event uh olympiads always  are uh  it's a unique event it's uh it's unlike  anything else in in the chess calendar  obviously because you see  uh the top players playing but it also  is a is a huge event where  uh players who normally don't get to you  know  play against and play next to uh the  very best in the world they get to  uh to to compete against them play  against them potentially at least in the  early rounds i guess  and  socialize with them as well which is  obviously a huge aspect of the olympiads  and  considering the fact that we don't have  we don't have much in the way of games  just yet the the social aspect maybe  gets discussed a bit more  uh  yeah it's uh  olympiads are absolutely absolutely  unique and uh  it's it's great that  uh it's about to get going again  yes